hello everyone started to be uploading
this late but I was waiting for all all
the games from the London chess classic
to finish to decide which game to show
and all the games were very interesting
I mean it's a really strong competition
played in Google headquarters very nice
but in the end I said sure this game as
all of you have been asking me to show
again between two engines and although
this is a game calls and versus Caruana
it's it's so correct it's almost like
it's played by two engines so let's see
this game Carson has the white pieces
and he plays d4 we have d5 and C for the
Queen's Gambit and D captures on c4 by
Caruana it's interesting josé raúl
capablanca always said that the best way
to refute a gambit is to buy accept it
but he also said that maybe in the case
of the Queens gambit it's maybe better
not to accept it but he captures on c4
okay III the old variation nice to f6
and Bishop captures on c4 e6 Knight to
f3 c 5 we have castles and bishops or a6
and Bishop to e2
this is probably probably a move to at
some point in the future not allow b5
which temple are not familiar with
Bishop to e2 Knight B to d7 Knight to c3
b6 now preparing to develop the bishop
and a strong diagonal efore by Carlson
and seek address on d4 not capture Sun
d4 and Bishop to be 7 now Caruana is now
attacking d4 pawn twice and the cross
and ignores that he plays Bishop to e3
and it's very interesting what happens
if the pawn is captured this is actually
this actually favors white for example
knife captures on e4 sorry after Bishop
to e3 Caruana played Bishop to c5 but
it's interesting what happens if the e4
pawn is captured for example if Knight
captures on e4 Knight captures on e4 and
the bishop captures on e4
you have Bishop to f3 now attacking the
bishop and for example Bishop captures
Queen captures
now the night is ready to jump to c6 and
after something like Bishop to c5 Knight
to c6 Queen to c7 you have rook a to c1
now white is preparing before and after
something like a five and a three rook a
to c8 now we play knife captures on a5 b
captures on a5 Bishop captures on c5
Queen sorry Knight captures on c5 and b4
now white is winning back the piece a
captures a captures and after black
castles rook captures on c5 Queen to d7
and rook F 2 c1
okay black does have an advantage on the
Queen side 4 points to 3 but white does
have a past be pawn this is better for
white and this is only one of the
variations that show why white is better
although it's I think it's a pretty much
the best move played by white and black
but okay after Bishop to e3 Bishop to c5
by caruana and now Carlsen protects d4
pawn would have three castles here Queen
to e1 preparing Queen to F to the guard
the bishop on e3 and also to add more
protection to the knight on d4 Rock the
c8 and now queen - f - B five rook a to
c1 and Queen to e7 a for cousin wants to
break open this a6 b5 phone structure be
captures than a fortnight capture some
before attacking the bishop sorry
Bishop to b6 and we have a nice to be
three now Bishop to c6 attacking the a4
knight Knight to c3 and rook to b8
Khurrana places this rook on a very nice
open B file with a tempo and on the
night also the knight moves this b2
phone will be hanging and Knight to a5
now we're a temple on this Bishop on c6
Bishop to a8 not allowing Knight any
free jumps covering b7 and c6 Knight the
c4 now costs and attacks the d6 bishop
cousin is trying to win that bishop pair
but Bishop to c5 rook after d1 and rook
after c8 and now both players
have all of their pieces developed and
already ready to play Knight to a4 again
Carson goes for the dark square Bishop
Bishop captures any three Queen captures
on III and Queen to b4 now threatening
the knight on a 4 and also pressuring
the B DuPont and here cross and played
Queen to a3 and this is this is this is
a good move but it seems he missed a
better one
instead of Queen to a3 defending the
knight also possible was Knight to c3
and it this does seem better for white
as the idea of rook captures night and
see for given up the rock for two pieces
doesn't work if rook captures Bishop
captures Queen captures okay now you
want two pieces for the rook but here
comes a five removing the f6 Knight the
defender of the d7 night and white is 0
with either winning the f6 Knight or the
d7 night and ever something like Queen
before he captures on f6 Knight captures
on f6 you are down a pawn but you're at
the exchange you know in in Carlson's
hands this is winning so after Queen
before Carson didn't go for the Knight
c3 he went Queen to a3 h6 now making
some breathing room for the king and
also preparing to expand on the Queen
the King side came to f1 g5 we have
looked to see 3 a 5 now Queen captures a
captures and rook to c1 came to f8 now
both players want to improve the
position of their King Knight to a5 King
to e7 came to f2 by Carson now rook
captures rook captures exchanging a pair
of rooks night to e8 now corona as the
knight on f6 wasn't really doing
anything didn't really have a bright
future there he's going for Knight to d6
and from there he will be controlling a
lot of important central squares came to
e3 further improving the position of the
King and Knight to d6 we have night the
c5 rook to c8 now pinning this night on
c5 and night 8 to b3 defending the c5
Knight f5 night capture Sunday 7 rook
captures on c1
nine captors and c1 and Keene captures
on d7 and we reached a pretty equal
ending or almost an identical ending
both players have four points on the
kingside 1b pond on the Queen side and a
bishop a bishop and the night so pretty
you know Carson does have his King a bit
further to the center so this is this is
what makes his position a bit better 9 2
D 3 by Carlson and we have F captures on
e 4f captures on e4 and the now King to
e7 and this is again a very nice a very
nice idea
again carlson is offering his eforp on
although this time you really can't take
it knife captures knife captures on e4
Falls to Bishop to f3 pinning the night
you're losing the piece if you move the
knight you lose the bishop on a8 and
Bishop and Bishop captures on e4 of
course losses tonight to c5 forking the
King and the bishop again you lose a
piece and the game so after F captures
only for King to e7 by Caruana now
capturing on e4 is definitely an idea
because there is no more 95 check d5 no
by Carlsen Knight to f5 check King f2
night to d4 and Bishop to d1 now this is
the famous relationship between a bishop
and denied both Bishop and Knight are
controlling the squares the other one
can go to b3 by Caruana and now Knight
to be for Bishop to d5 protecting the b3
pawn so now this d4 Knight can move g3
Bishop to c4 came to e3 Knight to f5
check King goes 3 4 and King to d7 and
this is a the greatest moment in the
game this is the moment I really enjoyed
in the game as I didn't really get to
get to watch the live coverage by a
syringe enter Hadi but I did catch a
glimpse of it and it was right about at
this point where Carlsen played the g4
and I was really surprised
I mean corona has a light square Bishop
why would you push g4 and give him a
target you
very nice Bonin g3 and h2 why not keep
them there on dark squares so it was was
a I don't know it seemed odd but if
Carson did play something like Bishop g4
instead of g4 you know the threatened
the knight on f5 this actually doesn't
work because Bishop f1 and now if you
capture the night a bishop to g2 check
first getting rid of the king and after
the King moves then he captures on f5
and now black is fine here another idea
would be for example after this Bishop
to f1 move not to capture immediately
but to try and triangulate the position
in your favor
for example Bishop to f3 and now the
bishop has to go back to the Queen side
Bishop to b5 as this pawn Knight and
Bishop are creating a wall so the White
King can't approach you to b3 pawn but
now Bishop to h5 and the bishop to f1
again and now Bishop to g4 so it's the
same position only now it's caranas more
so sort of triangulating the position
into your own favor but now returning to
the Queen side doesn't work because
Bishop captures on f5 so Bishop to G to
check would have to be played and after
King to d3 Bishop to f1 check this is
the reason why the whole Bishop to g4
idea doesn't work white now has to play
king - D - he has to keep an eye on the
e3 Square he can't allow night to e3
from their knight can jump to c4 to
attack the e5 pawn and in the future it
can go to f1 to attack the h2 and g3
pawn so unfortunately that doesn't work
if you play King c3 then like I said 93
would an attack on the Bishop Bishop age
5 and now 94 and you lose the e5 pawn so
cost and soul of this and after King g7
he decided to put his g4 move which I
thought you know okay it's weird but
it's cost and you know he's like like
the the endgame machine Knight to e7 and
Kings to d4 now the King is now getting
closer to the b3
porn bishop to f1 and unfortunately
better captures and b3 has to be played
again Carson has to move this Bishop
from the defense of the g3 pawn
unfortunately King c3 doesn't work you
know of course you want your bishop to
keep defending the g4 pawn and you would
enjoy capturing the b3 pawn with your
king but on IG 6 and now he'll lose the
e5 pawn and you know you did nothing
here
so after Bishop f1 they should capture
some B 3 but now Bishop to e2 by Caruana
as the bishop left the defense of the g4
pawn now Caruana attacks it with his own
light square Bishop h3 of course bishop
f1 are going for the h3 pawn as the
pawns are now on light squares they're
an easy target night the d3 and here we
have an interesting position again
corona now doesn't grab the h3 pawn
instead Knight to c6 check either
forcing the King to move away from the
defense of the d3 night or well if he
protects it then Bishop captures and the
Knight captures on e5 again with a
perfectly fine position for black but
here across some place King to c5 he
sacrifices a piece in the endgame but it
you'll see you'll see what I mean
Bishop captures on d3 and Bishop to a
for now pinning the knight on c6 and
corona plays Bishop to e4 now defending
the knight on c6 and it seems like
Carlsen can't win the piece back or 1
eyes up a piece but again it's a very
interesting position Keith the b6
Carlson doesn't allow caranas King to
move from from d7 and the king is
covering c7 the pawn is covering in d6
so the King can't move the King moves
anywhere else Bishop captures and c6
pretty much wins the game as this past
beef beep on will you know stroll down
to victory stroll up to victory so
Bishop to d5 was played before by
Carlson and after Bishop to b4 the
players agreed to a draw as no player
can really make progress here
b5 doesn't work in any ideas you just
you know
Bishop the King can't move anywhere it
loses the game
no pawns can can be moved forward so
it's a it's a dead draw so yeah like I
said I I decide to show this game it's
it's a very engine like game and all of
the other games ended in a draw as well
Cara Nakamura did have a pretty
interesting game against Vishwanathan
Anand although I kind of thought I kind
of thought of issue would win that but
in the end again it was a draw and I
didn't have time to show two games so
yeah that's the game from the first
round of the London chess classic played
in Google headquarters I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank William
Avery John MacDonald and peanuts
Springer for a contribution to my
channel thank a lot - really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon